grazie empatia creativa oggi si è
parlato di empatia sia parlata di
creatività
io vi avevo messo insieme un po di tempo
fa perché mi sembravano che siano due
parole che definiscano meglio il
concetto di sostenibilità l'empatia è
una relazione che si instaura con che
levante come un luogo con un clima e la
creatività e il grande motore che ti
permette di interpretare quelle empatia
e trasformarlo in un progetto volevo
farvi fare tre cose e questa è una cosa
che mi succede tutti i giorni ci
dobbiamo abituare l'idea che è più
importanti dividere richard non c'è
segnaletica che verrà è un momento delle
volte bisogna scegliere e questa è una
cosa che un architetto fa
quotidianamente scegliere di fare una
cosa piuttosto che un'altra di scegliere
una materia è una forma però ci sono
anche delle cose che ci dicano dove
andare e colga l'occasione che tra la
fia di male c'è cercavo avventure per
dirmi anche fra della strada noi
parliamo di sostenibilità delle volte in
maniera come dire anche una parola molto
sfruttata molto utilizzata da noi
abbiamo questa bellissima abitudine che
noi abbiamo sempre oltre quindi noi
siamo già andate oltre la per la
stazione di bilità però non abbiamo che
l'ha fatta no però partiamo da kyoto
quindi parliamo dal 91 ogni anno questi
25 anni che sono passati ogni anno
qualcosa sta succedendo cioè il mondo si
sta accorgendo che in tema ambientale un
tema sempre più importante è un tema che
è sempre più la gente è sempre qualcosa
che sta emergendo e piano piano negli
anni si è arrivati a fare tutte le
conferenze dell'onu come quella che
c'era pareggi tra una settimana e poi
arriva il papa che fa laudato sie e dice
una cosa bellissima
l'onu ci ha messo 21 anni per cercare di
costruire consenso intorno a questa idea
della
la sostenibilità il papa dice dobbiamo
riconciliarci con la natura una parola
di una semplicità che nasconde un cambio
di paradigma sostanziale noi stiamo è
parlato prima con lle industriali
abbiamo detto agli uomini al centro
l'uomo e il centro di tutto l'uomo e
anche contro ecc e al centro perché
anche contro la natura cioè noi abbiamo
usato una natura come un grande
strumento a decidere di riconciliarsi
vuol dire che noi siamo parte di un
sistema quindi non siamo contro ma siamo
con questo è un cambio straordinario e
lo dico dal mio punto di vista di
architetto perché una ri detto non è un
ecologista
io ho una grande simpatia ma poi quando
costruisco io uso un materia che è
trasformata dalla natura quindi non mi
posso dire non posso dire di essere un
puro però è anche importante capire
perché gli architetti sono da noi un
pochettino meno ma sono importanti ma
perché lo saranno di più
allora diciamo per darvi un'idea della
misura di che cosa sta succedendo
noi oggi abbiamo costruito 150 miliardi
di metri quadrati nel mondo questa è un
dato statistico no va bene dice fino a
oggi il pianeta porta 150 miliardi di
metri quadrati
ora questo di passione sembra molto no
non sai disk e dimensione però quando vi
faccio vedere questo però da qui al 2030
costruiremo metà di tutto quello che
abbiamo costruito noi vi potete
immaginare facilmente
ovviamente questo in italia non
succederà non lo faremo tutto questo
sforzo però succederà in tante altre
parti del mondo per fare 73 miliardi di
metri quadrati e con cosa che facciamo
che facciamo con il legno e facciamo col
cemento
lo facciamo usando l'acqua usando
l'energia e dove la prendiamo
e quindi che il tema fondamentale per
quello che credo sia molto importante
parlarne e trovare e che quello che
succederà nei prossimi 15 20 30 anni
è una sfida straordinaria per la
sopravvivenza perché comunque in molti
paesi
questo tema dell'ambiente questo tema
della crescita è visto come lo vedevamo
noi negli anni 50 quindi abbiamo un
problema
dobbiamo costruire meglio che dobbiamo
costruire con un'altra idea per farvi
vedere una dimensione parliamo molto di
sostenibilità che un tema che piacciono
inter ma anche molto molto importante e
molta sensibilità vi faccio vedere
questa amata questa è una mappa
modificata in funzione della produzione
dell'energia elettrica con il petrolio
ecco guardate l'italia siamo migliorati
un filino perché abbiamo fatto un po più
di energia rinnovabili ma questa è la
dimensione dei consumi è una nuova mappa
del mondo e un'altra geografia se vi
faccio vedere questa è stata mappe di
quello che si chiama ecologico footprint
e cioè quello di cui noi abbiamo la
superficie di cui abbiamo bisogno per il
nostro tenore di vita
se guarda questa mappa non posso dire
che l'europa sia la regione più
sostenibile del mondo
quindi è evidente che qui c'è qualcosa
che noi dobbiamo cambiare alla radice
però quindi è un problema legato ai
cambiamenti climatici ma qui la partita
si gioca sui cambiamenti culturali se
non mettiamo in pista questo cambiamento
queste cose non cambieranno quindi è
bene invece di buzzo buono
questo è un po più tecnico però abbiamo
degli obiettivi 2020 2030 2050 sono
tutti il tempo non è soltanto qualcosa
che scorre ma è uno strumento il che fa
qualcosa che vi dobbiamo usare per
arrivare a raggiungere quegli obiettivi
vi racconto una bella storia
l'architettura è immobile ma vi abbia
nella memoria
allora dopo tanti anni io a 55 anni
l'anno scorso mi hanno chiesto ti avevo
fatto un
un progetto per una scuola un asilo nido
questo è il mio asilo nido 1964 ma io
questo a 0 me lo ricordo perfettamente
non me lo ricordavo più
poi quando ho iniziato a fare questo
progetto del titolo di numero ricordo mi
ricordo e la vetrata medica del sole mi
ricordo chi di voi è stata la sera del
mio già il riposino a braccia conserte
era un incubo da stare share a proposito
di sistema e ducatista dei due ore
così con un bambino e che c'è sette
cavalli nelle gambe è veramente
difficile
parlavo io me lo ricordo questo cortile
questo piccolo quartiere che ero alto
così quindi quello spazio è un mero
ricordo bene quindi vuol dire che quelle
questo è oggi è una foto di gabriele
basilico quindi sono passati 50 anni ed
è ancora lì però questo mi ha fatto
pensare che gli edifici sono una prima
forma di educazione oggi si è parlato di
tante cose no
che cos'è che ti lascia quali sono
quelle cose che ti fanno poi scegliere
di fare un mestiere allora io mi sono mi
piace dirmelo che fosse falso
l'architetto perché sono spot adesiva di
una bella scuola perché quella scuola mi
ha lasciato qualcosa perché se me lo
sono ricordato non mi ricordo mi dà
tante cose di padre o quattro anni
perché di quella cosa di di
quell'edificio di quell'emozione io mi
sono ricordate ed è rimasta dentro di me
quindi vuol dire che quelli di fitch ha
pure se l'immobile ha viaggiato con me
nel tempo e quello ha influenzato la mia
vita no
sono processi come quello di andare alla
montessori che quel metodo di
insegnamento che ti fa venire fuori rosa
ma lo spazio è fondamentale la
costruzione dello spazio non
dimentichiamoci che noi tutti viviamo le
nostre emozioni
fondamentalmente anche con una certa
intimità legata che cosa lo staff ci
comunicano quindi a guardarsi io ho
imparato perché le cose essenziali sono
veramente poche
molte volte sono anche le più semplici
che vendono po inutilmente complicata
allora uno studio dice
gli studenti imparano di più se
studiarli un'aula ben progettata ma
ovviamente una scuola per no per niente
oppure se la luce la real a forme e
colori sono integrati questo disegno e
influenzano positivamente il sistema di
apprendimento allora vuol dire che il
design la qualità del design altra
sessione ha un'influenza diretta sul
sull'apprendimento e poi una cosa
banalissima il rapporto tra il confort
per l'apprendimento migliore è il
confort migliora l'apprendimento questo
ve lo dico perché ho fatto un progetto
per l'onu nella striscia di gaza
ora questi bambini vanno a scuola con 55
gradi è un po difficile pretendere che
ha un bambino l'estate a 55 gradi abbia
un'attenzione ok d'inverno sia seduto di
una scuola della ce ne sono otto e molto
difficile che un edificio scolastico e
ha un ruolo fondamentale ma anche un
ruolo fondamentale come è fatto io avevo
fatto questa scuola dove vengono fuori
le idee io non lo so e non credo neanche
che sia giusto aspetti nascono vengono
fuori da quello che è nella tua testa
faccio questo giro e parte da qui la
storia di pinocchio la conoscete tuta
geppetto geppetto e pinocchio dentro
questa balena pinocchio che nel buio
della balera vede un lucino raggi in
fondo attraverso la trovo geppetto c'è
questa gioia della storia
sceglierò io passo da lì e faccio questo
quindi questa scuola questo è un asilo
nido
non c'è niente è una grande balena
costruita tutta in legno che è una
scuola d'infanzia pubblica costruita a
guastalla vicino
ed è più tona storia perché l'abbiamo
fatta poi abbiamo fatto insieme agli
insegnanti e gli insegnanti hanno tante
cose da dirci io dico tante volte gli
architetti hanno anche un po di
arroganza
io non difendo la categoria e perché poi
la scuola la usano i bambini la usano
gli insegnati alla società ha bisogno di
entrare in empatia sennò poi le scuole
poi non funzionano questa scuola poi ha
due caratteristiche molto semplici cento
per cento di sicurezza sismica perché
non si possono mandare i bambini una
scuola che può cadere siamo alla follia
e 100 per cento di sicurezza ambientale
sana che può un bambino sapete un
bambino da 0 a 3 anni
non è che tocca le cose le cose le lecca
lecca lecca al muro al pavimento perché
deve sentire devi fare squadra fare che
se anche una birra dalle per non succede
niente da quando gli sembra come dire da
bici e quindi questo percorso della
scuola è stato un percorso costruito
insieme agli insegnanti insegnanti con i
cani bambini e quando abbiamo aperto le
porte i bambini si sono amiche giocare
con l'edificio che è stata la cosa che a
me ha sorpreso di più non solo erano
contenti perché non c'erano le aule non
c'era la finestra c'era la porta
abbiamo fatto questi diaframmi di vetro
che dividono le aule e il problema era è
la un architetto poi loro i bambini
santo piccole mani precisi battono
contro il realtà non è successo perché
in realtà un bambino di tre anni vive in
un mondo che è molto più piccolo non è
che ha una percezione dello spazio così
grave lo percepisce però poi vive nel
suo mondo e queste aule sono tutte in
comunicazione visiva in un grande spazio
io mi sono immaginato
speriamo che non escano troppi di
architetti da quella scuola perché già
ne abbiamo tanti in giro per la
questione immaginato che quei tre anni
in cui uno capisce come fate il mondo
quella scuola di un contributo nella
immaginazione loro capacità di viaggiare
dentro una cosa che non è la solita
stanza poi mi faccio vedere un'altra
cosa materia di tradizione ed
innovazione
l'innovazione nel nostro mestiere a due
fronti l'innovazione da una parte c'è un
tema sugli strumenti sono cambiati tutti
gli strumenti avevo iniziato quando ero
studente con la squadra che era a
treglio per chi fa il mio mestiere sai
cos'è quell'orribile strumento a china
che colava sabrina roba devastante poi
siamo abbassati e parole grosse poi
siamo passati a dei computer dr delle
scatole che aveva un ufficio con otto
persone a parigi non avevo abbastanza
spazio sul tavolo per mettere otto
computer perché danno enorme e
lavoravamo con autocad adesso quella
roba non c'è più
lavoriamo con altri strumenti con
strumenti digitali che sono un aumento
delle nostre capacità
ho fatto questo edificio indiana l'avevo
e l'ho fatto un po disordinato non
perfetto perché ha detto poi se
sbagliano a farlo non si vede perché
talal far casino ma non per gli africani
è inoltre gli africani per che però non
ha capacità manuale straordinaria per
fare questa cosa qui è stato uno dei
miei più tormenti degli ultimi tre anni
perché per fare delle cose imprecise
questo edificio finita ogni elemento è
diverso però dove sta la tecnologia in
quest'edificio fatto da 400 persone che
crollavano cemento ferro nella più
grande tradizionale sistema costruttivo
tutto il sapere stava nello strumento
digitale stava tutto lì e
nell'ottimizzazione delle forme e usando
un programma che si chiama grasshopper
che creiamo noi gestiamo la forma e poi
che cosa abbiamo fatto nella gestione di
questa forma questi pezzi sono partiti
la nostra computer sono andati in una
fabbrica una fabbrica fatto dei pezzi e
questi pezzi sono partiti per il ghana
tra me e che quel cantiere c'era un file
non sia da nient'altro e questo è molto
importante perché fa capire
quanto saranno importanti gli strumenti
di lavoro come ormai si lavora con
un'idea che diversa non si aveva rapito
il piano non si lavora solo spazio
tridimensionale si dovrà che un
programma che ha una capacità di
sviluppare più complessità è importante
volevo arrivare al punto perché volevo
raccontare nella storia bellissima
non è detto che le forme più semplici
siano le più efficaci e quindi un
programma come quello questo per esempio
una torre che abbiamo fatto 7.800
soluzioni non li abbiamo scelti tutto
ovviamente ma all'interno di questa
capacità per esempio di analizzare una
forma con una performance in questo caso
voglio quanta luce naturale posso dare
questo edificio o la capacità di analisi
che non è detto che mi dia come
risultato la forma più semplici ma mi
darà la forma più efficace per quel
risultato ambientale e questo la grande
forza di questi strumenti
oppure come costruiremo edifici con i
droni ora vi voglio raccontare una
storia di questo territorio non è che
tutto da buttare io l'energia e ho fatto
recente 250 anni e cosa vuoi che sia
nostra storia abbiamo migliaia di anni
di storia dell'architettura e quindi
nell idea del futuro mia idea di futuro
le rive di un futuro dove sia stata la
gestione delle risorse scarse forse quei
duemila anni di storie che stanno dietro
i due potrebbero essere molto utili
perché questi lavoravano l'energia non
ce l'avevano quindi vuol dire che per
migliaia di anni gli uomini anno sono
stati molto imparati cia hanno cercato
una complicità con la natura e vi faccio
vedere una storia stupenda 33 minuti
galileo galilei e li vedo che mi viene
la sua biografia racconta una storia
diversa intese ma gli piacevano state le
feste non andava a queste feste dove si
divertivano un sacco in questa villa di
costozza qua vicino
questa villa palladiana lui racconta è
stata una festa bellissima abbiamo
mangiato e bevuto c'era un caldo
micidiale e abbiamo trovato una griglia
per terra
da qui si vede l'aria fresca e ci siamo
addormentati su questa griglia ci faccia
uscire l'aria fresca da una griglia in
una villa del 1500
allora avevano costruzione averla
attaccata questo covolo che è una specie
di grotta questa grotta ovviamente a
destra dell'aria fredda fresca e umida
che per suo peso scende verso il basso
entra nella villa e desse da questa
griglia e condiziona in estate questa
casa non c'è una macchina non c'è niente
c'è solo un principio di relazione
empatica con l'ambiente ora poi questa
villa poi lui è stato male perché è
venuta una congestione sua amica maya
mezzo morto perché anche lui si è
addormentato ubriaco su questa roba che
pensate immaginare questa guida
tu non potresti dire che questo un un
eco building
adesso si chiama o una bio architettura
parola al terrificante no è una bella
architettura che ha una capacità di
relazione ora per chiudere questa villa
era molto famosa perché l'aria fredda
che scendeva entrava nel palazzo
scendeva anche nel giardino e nel
giardino si era fatto atterrare
questo è il terrazzo vedono dei piccoli
muretti intorno all'ora le signore del
tempo andavano con quei vestiti molto
lunghi e si diceva che era una villa un
po peccaminosa perché cambio camminavano
in questo giardino
l'aria fredda e sta a pavimento del
giardino viene risucchiata dal calore
del corpo che a 35 gradi e queste specie
di lingue di aria fredda sembravano
delle mani bile che toccavano il culo
alle signore di questa storia a voi
capite la bellezza diventa è legata a un
rapporto di empatia tra l'architettura e
l'ambiente un fenomeno straordinario